en même temps il faut attendre avant que
ce soit mort c'est déjà mort
donc là si je veux ce soir
fais-toi plaisir ce soir c'est juste une
question
demain il y a pas de problème tu veux
que je te dise ce weekend amuse-toi ah
non
je me filme
exactement comment moi de nuit
[Musique]
avec ça arrêtez avec ça je le dis je le
redis ne te mets pas la rate au bouillon
pour cette affaire c'est une façade tu
passes à autre chose ça fait 6 ans
avec toutes les six ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
être amoureux tu sais ce que ça veut
dire non
ça ça m'intéresse
être amoureux
définition je fais le tour je vous le
dis pas
jusqu'à Bagnolet
être amoureux
ouvrez les portes quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
être amoureux
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
[Applaudissements]
un degré de mensonge
ce serait pas la définition d'un
philosophe
[Applaudissements]
une bonne définition
être amoureux
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un double appel
être amoureux
être ne pas être
un KX
être amoureux
je suis amoureux si et seulement si
si et seulement si
de fonds
ça va être fort je vous le dis ça va
être fort
j'ai à tout moment
mais pas à tout moment
[Applaudissements]
concomitante
j'ai bien fait de pas écrire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de vivre
en adéquation
[Rires]
avec la personne suce nommée
inversement proportionnel
dans un
avenir proche la phrase est un peu
longue
l'intermédiaire privilégiée dans un
avenir proche l'intermédiaire privée
de mon corps mon âme au cœur et mon Z
c'est bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
qui veut relire alors pas Castaldi hein
être amoureux être amoureux être
amoureux je suis amoureuse ta gueule
pas d'artifice
être amoureux je suis amoureux si et
seulement si j'ai à tout moment l'envie
concomitante de vivre en adéquation avec
la personne susnommée
inversement proportionnel sera dans un
avenir proche l'intermédiaire privilégié
de mon corps de mon âme de mon cœur et
de mon homme
je crois que c'est clair
Aristote
Leroy
[Musique]
[Rires]
merliner ça à mon avis il va sortir son
rouge